thank you
good afternoon everybody this is the
public protection subcommittee meeting
thursday 19th of november we are being
broadcast live on youtube and
in attendance our council is from the
committee and offices of the council
we have apologies from councillor
bunting
excuse me of course hunting
councillor churchill and
i'm sorry natalie could you compare me
to the other ones
that's widowfield castle don't feel
sorry the most important
of course uh that's right uh we have no
apologies uh elsewhere although
we are expecting the chair to to join us
who's having i.t issues
later on agenda item number two
could somebody on the committee please
um receive
and second the minutes from the meeting
on
september the 17th
right right
was that council of alton and council
brothers and secondly yes
thank you uh the gender item number
three
is there any urgent business that needs
to be brought before
the committee at this stage no chair
thank you very much okay um
at this point we'd like to adjourn this
meeting uh briefly
uh whilst we await the arrival of
um submission to the committee and we'll
readjourn
around 4 30.
thank you